so how long have you been Antonin again
no uh and just sort of happened I seem
to mess it up almost every time
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner dr. PIM I actually heard
what happened to you do open up the
quantum realm that's when his crazy
could be ghosts and like walks through
walls and stuff
slowly otech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house
happy because we robbed you
do you remember that's us feeling
Chesley practice this poker game
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65 if you two are
finished comparing sizes 65
[Music]
I just have one question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught
[Music]
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
you
you